good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1193 object
class safe special containment
procedures the borehole containing a CP
1193 o1 is to be capped with a tungsten
steel grate containing a locking 2 point
5 centimeter endoscopy aperture had 48
hour intervals the borehole is to be
endoscopy inspected to a depth of 4
kilometers for further manifestations of
SCP 1193 o1 seismographic monitoring
devices are posted at 2 7 & 11 kilometer
depth alongside the SCP 11 9301 borehole
seismic readings consistent with
subterranean movement are to be reported
immediately to site director Iqbal in
the event of subterranean containment
breach containment staff are to execute
protocol 47 3a severing SCP 1190 301
below the 5th elbow and back filling
remaining portions of the borehole with
pressurized concrete the basement
containing SCP 1193 is to be monitored
at all times by a foundation
interrogator SCP 1190 302 is to be
answered on or before the third ring
interrogator should attempt to elicit
self directed responses from a CP 1193
o1 responses which implicates size body
plant location or further manifestations
are to be recorded in document SCP 1193
to LTR
description sep11 9301 is a genetically
normal human arm of unusual length
located in a drainage pipe inside the
basement of a telephone switching
station in Scottsdale Arizona
10 centimeters below the drainage gate
the arm terminates in an unremarkable
human hand of indeterminate gender upon
initial examination the arm was believed
to extend through the drainage pipe to a
depth of 35 meters subsequent endoscopic
investigation demonstrated that the arm
extends to at least a depth of 71 km/h
apparent difficulty through the morovich
ikh discontinuity and the upper mantle
with regularly spaced elbows every 4
kilometers elbows below a depth of 26
kilometers are slightly retro flexed to
accommodate a 9 degree southward bend in
the drainage borehole continued
endoscopic investigation into the SCP
1193 o1 borehole is suspended due to
presently intractable engineering
constraints communications via CP 1193
o2 mostly concerning SCP 1193 old ones
oven and refrigerator indicate that SCP
1193 l1 may lack conventional thermal
reception and then it is experiencing no
substantial discomfort despite borehole
temperatures in excess of 674 degrees
centigrade SCP 1193 o2 is a GPO 746
telephone topaz Yello manufactured in
1971 it's dimensions precluded having
been delivered to the site via the
borehole containment teams present
working theory is that it was installed
topside for the purpose of communicating
with SCP 1193 o1 installation was
conducted by unknown parties by unknown
means for unknown purposes the rotary
dial has been glued into place rendering
it unsuitable for outgoing phone calls
it is attached to a conventional twisted
pair line which enters the drainage pipe
containing a CP 1193 o1 and descends
parallel to SCP 1193 o1 until endoscopy
is no longer practice about between 38
and 1034 hours mounted standard time
each weekday the phone will ring five
times if answered an unidentified voice
will willingly engaging conversation
with SCP personnel the voice on the
other end of the line invariably claims
to be a human being and regularly
mistakes the individual on the other end
of the phone for an authority figure
interrogation to date has therefore been
relatively uncomplicated
notable parallels exist between
information elicited by SCP 1190 302 and
demonstrable facts have found a CP 1193
o1 to date anomalous information
received via SCP 1190 302 has included
references to human features but
anomalous body plan references to
insensitivity to heat or cold references
to a cousin or other relative who will
soon arrive to pick him up
references to discomfort and boredom at
confinement references to minor seismic
events along the little chino fault
complex references to discomfort at
having a
more other body part restrained as by
handcuffs a jelly jar 8 pipe a caste or
in one instance it gopher hole at
present data related to SCP 1193 o1 size
physical form and body plan beyond the
parts visible through and the scopic
investigation she would be regarded as
provisional for contingent protocols and
physiological testing data consult
document RT M R Delta this is document
SCP 1193 - LT r7
[Music]
good morning and who may I ask is
calling and where are you now David
sorry whispers dr. Hasan Iqbal director
of research Oh from the hospital that's
right
so when does the cast come off I'm sorry
the cast of my bottom arm when does it
come off and to understand that you've
got a cast on your bottom arm I don't
understand
which arm is that the bottom one can you
take it off I've already been in the
hospital for three months seems like it
should be about time you say you're in a
hospital
yeah you should know you're the one who
put me there I think you must have me
mistaken for someone else look if you
can help me put someone who knows what
he's talking about on the line I'm
afraid I'm the only one here fine just
tell me what someone competent to get
and this is document SCP 1193 2lt r8
where are you the fire department I'm
sorry - am i hearing you correctly okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Kareem el Ashman we Justin day
Thomas Morin Curie kuma and jayvo jack
crystal spice goddess of Donuts my
archive curator Nick Joseph Lewis ooh
agent vamp King modding the wanderer and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you